بعد الاعلان عن تنظيم حفل ستاند اب كوميدي
للفنان الامريكي كيفن هارت لاول مره في
القاهره في فبراير المقبل صارت ضجه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[تصفيق]
موجه من الغضب وحمل على مواقع التواصل
لالغاء الحفله على خلفيه تصريحات السابقه
لهارد اتهمته بالعنصريه وتزوير التاريخ
كان كيف انهارت قد صرح من قبل بانه يجب ان
يتعلم الاولاد التاريخ الحقيقي للافارقه
السود عندما كانوا ملوكا في مصر وليس فقط
لحقبه العبوديه التي يتم ترسيخها في
التعليم الامريكي
[موسيقى]
وهو تصريح الذي اعتبروه تزويرا لتاريخ
المصري القديم
المنتشره في امريكا والتي تزعم ان الحضاره
المصريه اصولها افريقيه
[موسيقى]
علماء الاثار من جانبهم نفسه صحه هذه
المعلومات
[موسيقى]
الشركه المنظمه للحفل لم تعلق على هذه
الدعوات واكتفت بكلمه لا تعليق في ما يبدو
ان الحفل سيقام في موعده سمر بشات لصباح
العربيه من القاهره